there is nothing leisurely about
competitive eating this is an aerobic
activity it's like running a marathon
and a hundred yard dash at the same time
except your feet are standing still but
your stomach just moving it up 100 miles
an hour
my name is Crazy Legs Conti I've been a
major-league eater for 15 years I cannot
think of a single food that has not gone
competitively into my stomach
make no mistake competitive eating is a
real sport it's muscle memory your
stomach mind and body has it
if you've prepared well enough what can
go wrong are not the voices in your
stomach but the voices in your head
you're getting full Cantus is going
forever when will this end your strategy
has to be spot-on in terms of your
technique but you don't actually taste
the food at about 15 I start to feel the
drag on peristalsis and my system in
competitive eating we call it the wall
that's where your body just says stop
you're sweating your cheeks are puffed
out you're exhausted the last two
minutes are where dreams are made and
realities are broken that's the most
difficult part of any contest there is
no magic in the aftermath of competitive
eating we digest everything we eat I
need to continually drink liquids to
kind of create a log flume likeability
in my system the minimum for any
competitive eating contest is 24 hours
before I feel human and by human I mean
as a casual diner again I find the
activity of competitive eating to be
grueling and challenging and esoteric
but rewarding I'm going to eat for the
rest of my life I might as well do it
competitively